is there an update on frozen - yeah
we've begun working on it and that's all
I can really tell you well grab your
popcorn and get ready because Disney
just dropped the trailer for frozen -
and it is epic
in the clip we see Anna and Elsa are
back at it with a new adventure and this
time it's a little bit darker Elsa the
past is not what it seems
you must find the truth
[Music]
across the enchanted Lambs and into the
unknown
[Music]
but the girls aren't alone on their
journey Kristoff Sven and Olaf are there
to help too we have always feared houses
powers were too much for this world
now we must hope
[Music]
they are enough
[Music]
I won't let anything happen to her I
love a cute protective sister moment so
here's what we learned from the trailer
Elsa is trying to figure out the source
of her magical ice powers there's an
underwater horse named NOK who uses the
power of the ocean to guard the secrets
of the forest the rock trolls are alive
and well and back to share their ancient
wisdom with the sisters and shed more
light on Elsa's power which you might
remember they helped conceal in the
original flicks we also catch a glimpse
at a young Anna and Elsa a few
marshmallow light creatures what looks
like the land of eternal fall and some
crazy a purple wildfire that threatens
the game and check it out the girls have
some new dresses Kristoff gets to use
his new sled the one on a gifted him at
the end of frozen and don't blink or
you'll miss it there's a glimpse of
Elsa's ice castle of course idina menzel
kristen bell jonathan groff and josh gad
are reprising their roles for the film
sequel while Evan Rachel Wood and
sterling K Brown join as new characters
it's a pretty awesome family that I'm a
part of it's a great group of creative
people and any opportunity to get back
and hang with them and do our thing like
we did on the first one would be just a
lot of fun and you know I just consider
the whole thing's just a gift that keeps
on giving fans will have to wait until
November 22nd to see frozen - in
theaters and if it's anything like the
first flick it'll be a big moneymaker
[Music]
frozen became the highest-grossing
animated film of all time do you feel
the pressure I don't feel the pressure I
feel in good hands with Paul Disney
family and the creative team they're the
most ingenious people I know and this is
nice to kind of go in the studio no
makeup and play you know the movie
success surprised me I mean it was kind
of crazy yeah was I mean we I mean I
think we all thought it was good but you
never know when the right recipe is
gonna hit at the right time and people
were just ready for it
and we're very grateful I cannot wait to
see frozen to you the countdown really
is on over here and of course we'll be
with the stars of the flick as the clock
counts down to bring you all the Intel
so be sure to keep it locked right here
on ET until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]